hello everybody hope they are good I've
already checked High block the
liquidation levels and liquidation hit
maps and the other book and to be honest
with you today I haven't found any
information that I find very useful I
found the that a bit contradictive today
so we are only going to talk about the
chart because I think that the chart is
already providing enough information by
itself so we're want to stick to the
Chart all right I want to talk about
what happened yesterday yesterday was
kind of a chaotic day a lot of
volatility again a n love volatility and
uh in yesterday's video pretty much in
life because I was still filming at that
point we saw uh this stop hunt that we
were talking about in that video and
also in the previous Day's Video and it
was that stop hunt to
53,000 we got to
52,900 let's check
exactly to
52,900 right and from then then we saw
the a massive
rejection okay that's your rejection get
back inside the range I executed this
trade myself in the 15 minutes time
frame as soon as I saw this candle
closing in back inside the range as I
told you yesterday's video then I'll go
short and I'm going to aim for the 4
hours 50a uh it was going to be the next
uh support all right uh so that was from
52250 is all all the way down to let me
go to the 4our time frame all the way
down to ,900 and you can see how the 4H
hour 50 May acted as support then we saw
a bounce back inside the range I didn't
expect this one to be honest we created
a monster week because that's a very
long week look at that and then when I
open the chart I already open a bit late
but I I wish that I open it even later
because uh when I open the the chart we
already closed this candle and we were
forming this candle right here and we
were halfway so I have to think fast and
I the first thing that I saw obviously
was this long week I'm sure how many of
you also saw saw this uh long week and
when you see a long week according to
the Quick Fill strategy that I use long
weeks get filled it's as simple as that
long weeks get to get filled the
percentage is huge so when I see a long
week like this all that my brain is
thinking is I have to trade towards that
week it's as simple as that okay um if
we go through the chart try to find a a
week as long as this one it's kind of
difficult to be
honest um for example you can see a few
here you can see this long week that
gets filled you can see this long week
that gets filled so you can see how long
weeks are quite good uh it's a good way
to trade at least for me it works great
okay and I can explained in this video
everything about the Quick Fill strategy
because it would take me uh a very long
time so that's why it's in the course uh
now the course has been currently full
for the last uh month and a half but I
am thinking to open new spots for maybe
in a couple of weeks because I see many
of you asking me about it so stay tuned
to the telegram channel that it's free I
invite you to to join there and also X
because maybe this week I open more
spaces okay now what I want to say about
what happened yesterday that I didn't
finish well that this week was already
forming and I have to think fast I
thought okay I want to trade towards
this week so I was looking for liquidity
pools we already retraced this one we
were retracing this one and then we have
this one to the upside and I thought
look this one seems even too high to get
to okay this liquidity pull here so what
I decided was to open a short sorry I
don't want foni I want this to open a
short at this liquidity pool at 100% of
that retrace what happened well that I
was grown and price continued going
higher even went to the range highs
where I added more short to my position
because I didn't see it going higher and
to be honest I kept seeing this long
week and that gave me a lot of
conviction okay because as I've told you
look look back in the chart tell me a
quick of this size that hasn't been fil
the straight away in the 1 hour time
frame okay it's it gets filled usually
very fast usually 24 hours 36 hours max
so I was looking at this week and saying
okay it's going to get failed I'm going
to to my position I get it at the range
SI cuz it was a very strong resistance
you can see here all the time getting
rejected at that
level and then from there um I know we
dropped even lower but I wanted to close
all my position at the 50% of the the
week the 50% of the week is here so it
was in these two candles when I closed
well in this red candle now you might
think but we have a liquidity pull to
the
downside and you are right about it look
at this okay let me remove the 4 Hour 50
this is the one hour time frame look at
that okay it's a liquidity pool that is
very very big and we should retrace it
and I agree with you I think that should
retrace this now the question is is it
going to happen now straight away or
this at Le what I think I had the trade
towards the week week gets filled I'm
out of the trade and now I look for the
next trade different setup totally okay
I'm not interested to open to be in a
short from here if I short now towards
the liquidity pool I prefer to open a
new short around here if I see that
trigger developing now what is that
trigger you might wondering well let's
go to the 4 hours time frame you're
going to see this very clear get my 50
ma the first thing is that I would like
to see candlesticks closing below the
4our 50 Ma and testing it as resistance
you can see how this red candle closed
below the level but right now we are
recover it we're not testing it as
resistance okay and I would like to see
at least two candlesticks in the 4our
time frame testing the 4our 50 ma as
resistance that means that this
Candlestick should close red okay Bel
the 4our 50 MAA and the next one too if
that happens then we'll have two
candlesticks closing below and well
sorry testing it as resistance and I'll
be opening a short with the third
Candlestick okay because I think that
then the risk to the downside would
increase and the probabilties for us to
reach to this level 50,000 well
49,800 would be higher okay so that is
the next setup that I'm looking at I
want to see candlesticks at least two
candlesticks test the 4H 50 m resistance
then with the third one I'll enter my
short simple as that okay you don't have
to over complicate things sometimes it's
as simple as that now the thing is would
I want to close my trade at the 100%
retrace of this liquidity pool that's a
49,83664 and that is
exactly at
50,000 very strong psychological level
we usually can see manipulation at this
level you can even see here look what
happened here Works to the upsite but
price not progressing any further it
wasn't going higher at exactly 50,000
why well simply because the market maker
was inducing the retail Trader to go
long with these breakouts because if you
go into the one hour time frame or the
15 minutes time frame this might appear
as little breakouts but at the end what
they did is like retrace price back down
and what they were doing that was
basically building Longs with this WIS
okay that's how the market Maker Works
they just build positions they don't go
all in in one order no no no they build
positions over a period of time it's as
simple as that now for the sake of
$170 between these two levels that I've
just marked I'm going to move the lower
one because I don't want to to risk the
price does the same here drops to this
level then maybe a deviation here or
some weeks here a 50,000 and another
reversal back inside the range that can
happen so I'm not willing to risk that
okay myself look at that this is how I
want this Candlestick to close to close
like well not anymore like a minute ago
okay below the purple line okay if he
closes below the purple line and that's
in 1 hour and 12 minutes and the next 4
hours time frame too two then that means
that in exactly 5 hours and 15 minutes
I'll be going short that's how I trade
all right um so right now I can
literally turn off the charts for the
next 5 hours and then open the chart
again see if that played out and if it
play it out that's my trigger and I can
move into a short okay look at that
that's how I wanted to close you see
that but still we have an hour so um
that's um my next setup that I'm looking
at I've already closed the short I'm not
in a position I'm waiting if I if price
starts to drop now like this in this in
this candle stick in the next hour you
know I have no problem tomorrow I'll be
looking for a new trade but I cannot RK
to take a trade now before this candles
close on the next one because if not
this might be a deviation below the 4H
hour 50 ma recovery go back up I gu
stopped I don't want to get stopped out
okay uh as simple as that
so another thing that I'm looking at
that is giving me conviction that this
could be in play is that if we notice
this is an M
pattern you can see that very clear
you're not going to find M
patterns uh much clearer than this okay
that's very clear now usually with the
nend patterns what you are going to see
is that with the second leg up ideally
you'll see a sweep of the highs we've
seen that because if you notice this
High get swept by this other high okay
okay and then what then you want to see
is a drop with a second leg down all
right and you want to see a
retrace and
continuation and that retrace here that
I'm talking about it might have already
happened here check this out okay I want
you to check this out you can see that
with this Candlestick in this literally
this one in in in this current
Candlestick for our for our time frame
we've done a little retest of the range
flows as
resistance so close in the Candlestick
like this below the purple line This
Candlestick and the next one then I'll
be going short okay so I'm waiting for
this Candlestick to close the next one
also to close below the purple line then
there'll be two candlesticks closing
below the purple line and then I can go
short from 51,000 to 50,000 okay that's
a $1,000 move for the day I'm pretty
happy with that not going to lie
so that's what I'm looking at I think
it's as simple as that and I don't want
to make the video any longer now this
indicator is indicator that I'm working
on you can see how it's marking the
weeks it marks the 50% and the 100% uh
it works in all the time frames go to
the one hour time frame you see working
there and marking for example this week
here or that week over there okay it
works in all the time frames mark this
liquidity pool that's my
target but it's not fair finished okay
this indicator is not finished we still
fixing some books because obviously when
you work on on something like this books
appear and before you guys try it out I
want uh to be as as good or as less
imperfect as possible okay um for that
what we're going to do is we're going to
open a beta test in a couple of weeks
because I think indicator is going to be
well most of the books will be fixed in
a couple of weeks then I can open a a
bet test that's basically um it's going
to be probably a period of a couple of
months two 3 four months I don't know
where a selected group of people
including myself we're going to test
this um this indicator we're going to
have a dedicate a telegram Channel
private just for this to give some
feedback I'll create some polls so you
can decide some things how to uh change
the indicator and make it better and
then once it's fully done
then I'll release it for free to the
public so everybody can have access to
it but the beta test is going to take a
couple of months and it's going to be a
bit tough now for the beta test only two
kinds of people can participate a
students from the course and this
applies to all the students the first uh
group course that I did was in February
of last year so even those guys that did
it for free cuz that was my first group
so I wanted to do it for free those guys
I want to have access to the to the beta
test and also the guys that are
finishing the course now everybody that
has done the course is going to have
access to it now perhaps I open this
week new slots for the course because
some of you are asking about it and if I
open that this week it's probably going
to probably the course will start in a
couple of weeks at the start of March
and of course newer students will also
have access to the beta test and also um
users well active Traders using my
referral link of bankex because it's a
nice way to support my content and I
appreciate it it gives me passive income
that's the truth because these are
basically um fees that exchange would
keep otherwise and instead I keep a
percentage so I want to support
obviously everybody that it's uh
contributing to support my content
through that so I think it's a nice way
that they get access to the beta test to
to kind of say thank you so stay tuned
to the telegram channel it's free it's
in the description uh you don't have to
do anything you can just enter and wait
for me to post it's a telegram Channel
and I'll be posting when the course when
the course is open because it's probably
going to be a Sal out pretty quickly and
also want to post it on Twitter on next
so um feel free to follow me on those
two
platforms and yep that's pretty much I
wanted to say I finished the video quite
quickly so I could speak a bit about
this I usually don't so anyway thank you
so much for watching guys and I'll see
you
soon